at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by peloton and I'd heard
about peloton over and over again but I
ended up getting a peloton bike in the
whole system after I saw my buddy Kevin
Rose I've known him forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic I asked him as a dude
you look great what the hell have you
been up to because he's always doing a
weird diet or another but it only lasts
like a week or two so he always
regresses to the mean after like 75
beers and he said I've been doing
peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention because
Kevin does nothing five days a week and
you know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes in your schedule or
making it to a studio with some type of
commute etc new classes are added every
day and this includes options led by
elite New York City instructors in your
own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you
but we usually just use classes on
demand I really like Matt Wilbur's and
design high intensity training sessions
that are shorter like 20 minutes and I
think Kevin's favorite is Alex and
everyone seems to have their favorite
instructor or you can select by music
duration and so on each peloton bike
includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not and it fits
with no problem so peloton is offering
all of you guys listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show a special offer and it is
actually special visit one peloton
that's Oh n e PE l OT o n one peloton
calm and enter the code Tim all caps TI
m at checkout to receive $100 off
accessories with your peloton bike
purchase now you might say man
accessories wait I don't need fancy
towels or whatever other supplemental
bits and pieces no the shoes you need
you need the clip in shoes and those are
in the accessory category so there's
$100 off is a very legit hundred dollars
off so if you want to get in your
workouts if you want a convenient and
really entertaining way to do
high-intensity interval training or
anything else or you just want to get a
fantastic gift for someone
check out peloton one pallet on.com and
enter the code to Tim again that's Ont
PE l o t-- o-- n dot-com and enter the
code Tim at checkout to receive $100 off
any accessories including the shoes that
you will want to get check it out
one peloton comm code Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for ages
since even before podcasting was the
thing and I've used them for all sorts
of graphic design needs they are fast
and they are convenient whether you need
a logo a website book cover or anything
else I've done competitions for instance
for book covers related to the 4-hour
body 99designs makes great design
accessible to everyone and it makes the
process so much easier and I use them
recently for artwork and illustrations
inside of my cow of Seneca set of books
so this is a collection of stoic writing
and modern interviews and so on so for
the town of Seneca I decided to use
their one-to-one project surface in this
case you invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied and
the artwork just blew my mind you have
to check it out I kid you not so you can
check out some of the artwork from Tov
Seneca as well as some artwork and logos
and so on that your fellow listeners
have had made at 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim that's 99designs com
forward slash Tim I really suggest you
check it out and right now you guys can
receive a free $99 upgrade on your first
project this gets you I think a hundred
and thirty percent more submission so
people who want to work with you and
give you first drafts of what you're
looking for to access your free design
please visit 99designs dot-com forward
slash Tim and click the link on the
landing page that's 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim
today's guest is M sunjin PhD oh my
goodness are you in for a treat you're
gonna hear about everything from monkeys
and birthday cakes to building a
personal board of advisors for yourself
I'm not going to give you the bio right
this second because you're gonna hear it
from a live recording the live recording
was taken at sixth and I very famous
historic location in Washington DC sixth
and I org you can check them out where I
interviewed two different people in
separate sessions Steve Case the
co-founder of AOL and known for many
other things and then M sanjayan
who you are going to hear from next
enjoy everybody loosened up Limbert
alright let's just jump right into it so
this is gonna be fun
I've been looking forward to this trying
to make this happen
hoping to make this happen and here we
are so let me just jump right into it
our next guest is M
sunjin PhD a global conservation
scientist specializing in how nature
preserves and enhances human life he
serves as conservation internationals
chief executive officer we have met
before and we'll get into that sonjin
joint CI in 2014 as executive vice
president senior scientist has led
several key divisions divisions just
underscoring that for you guys including
oceans science development branded
communications and strategic priorities
that sounds like a lot Sanjay and holds
a doctorate from the University of
California Santa Cruz and his
peer-reviewed scientific work has been
published in journals including science
nature and conservation biology he is a
visiting researcher at UCLA and a
distinguished professor of practice at
Arizona State University raised in
Southeast Asia and Africa
Sandra's background expertise provided a
unique lens for hosting and co-hosting a
range of documentaries for PBS BBC
Discovery and Showtime most recently he
hosted the University of California and
Fox media's climate lab series sonjin is
a Disneynature ambassador a Caddo Fellow
at the Aspen Institute and a member of
the National Geographic Society
Explorers council he posts frequently
from his expeditions at M sanjayan
that's sa NJ aya n on Twitter please
welcome to the stage
I'm sanshin all right so I want to start
with something we were discussing very
briefly before we get up here and I said
wait wait wait don't tell me I want to
hear the story but let's save it what is
your full name
ooh audio audio mic microphone check
hello hello hello there we go okay
can you guys hear me
first of all Tim call me up yesterday
when I was in Botswana getting on a
flight 22 hours to get here and said hey
you in DC because I'm gonna be there and
I'm like yeah but I'm not just arriving
but that Denny's that well I'm there for
24 hours but hey I'd love to see you do
you want to come to this thing oh by the
way do you want to be on stage and I'm
not very good at saying no which we'll
get to having listened to his last
podcast about get saying no to things
but I feel so much better today because
I realize it isn't a last-minute
invitation because he did the same thing
to Steve Case okay so I'm a Tamil I'm
from Sri Lanka and some of us are just
given one names so on my birth
certificate
it just says Sanjay but my dad's name
which I used as a last name like from my
American passport is muta Linga and I
don't use it much for two reasons I've
actually never one reason to the obvious
one because if someone said dr. meconium
it being my dad would look not me so I
don't associate it distinctly with nice
myself that's the reason I've told
everyone the reason I don't tend to use
it and never ever told this to anyone at
least not on the public audience is that
when I came to America people have this
obsession about what your name means
they always ask you like oh wow cool
name
what does that name means I don't go
around going like Michael what is your
name means I'm an angel or like it
doesn't come up but they do tend to ask
that of foreigners for some reason and
the problem is this name with the Lingam
what literally means giant pearl penis
until I was like a junior I was deeply
like conscious of that and I would never
say it and then one day in a bar somehow
it kind of blurted out and the reaction
I got was really and so then it became
not a problem anymore so the thing that
sounds like a last name meaning a you
know what Lingam is right you could get
it like look it up like Lingam that's
like you know a phallic representation
so it's like penis it's the same thing
and what's the means pearl it's actually
mother-of-pearl
so yeah that's exactly it's like the
Hope Diamond of penises yeah I know it's
just last name ever
I know or did last name yeah there we go
yeah so I think the most logical segue
here is to ask you about bullying during
your childhood we've suffered many of us
through bullying and I want to talk
about a monkey a monkey who stole a
birthday cake can you explain what what
the hell is going on here how did yeah
could you please explain monkey birthday
cake story well I'll do that very
quickly because they actually comes to
one of your questions that you asked
people which is about a strange habit so
one of my strange habits unusual habit
is that I like to do something new
something I've never done before I like
to try it on my birthday and that's a
tradition it's been everything from like
writing poetry to learning how to
snowboard when I was 45 to fly fishing
to learning to bake a beef wellington
right so it could be anything but I've
never done it before and I did this I
Institute this as a practice
about 15 years ago because I would
always get very depressed on my birthday
because what happened on my birthday was
that very the long story I have to do it
very short so very quick version is no
no no quick version doesn't have to be
sure it's over five years old we just
moved from Sri Lanka to Sierra Leone
West Africa and not just in town we were
like in the in the bush in the country
like way out there and my mother
amazingly I guess so in Sri Lanka I was
like a little prince I had these amazing
cakes like you know battleship cake you
know entire zoo cake I mean it was like
that kind of cake and then we went to
Sierra Leone and my mother and we we had
to sort of flee Sri Lanka in the middle
of the night you know because of trouble
in the country and my mom actually
packed which is amazing I think back on
it like a pound of flour and like icing
sugar because we came to Sierra Leone on
December 4th and my birthday was on
December 26 and she knew this and so out
there in the middle of the jungle she
baked me a cake
it was the simple little round cake with
with chocolate frosting which is like
the simplest frosting you can Bay get
right basically you can make it almost
any way and I didn't like it so I was
crying as weeping I was unhappy about it
my mother meant she got tired she said
you know like that's it I'm here's the
cake put it on the table she goes in to
take a bath and I kind of stopped crying
as you do when you're five and no one's
watching and I walk into the living room
and now the corner my I catch a glimpse
of something I turn and look and there's
a monkey and the monkey is holding my
cake and the monkey looks at me I look
at the monkey we're both like and then
it jumps it jumps on the windowsill and
flees it like goes gone and I'd go
screening in the cake that kind of thing
when mom comes out she's like woried
petrified she's only been the country
for a few days at that point like 22
days shaking me she's like are you okay
are you okay
like the cake the cake cake she ghost
the window she goes to had no cake there
she goes to the window and our house is
on stilts to avoid flooding in the in
the rain forest and and she looks down
and the cake is down there and she turns
to me and she says you wicked wicked
child
your birthday is canceled
forever we will never do birthday again
just wait till little father comes home
and that was it and now I'm on the floor
I'm like because African child injustice
it's like the worst thing ever so since
then like birthdays have been really
really difficult I mean it's also on
December 26 which is not great you know
for lots of reasons and so it creates
this gigantic sense of anxiety it's
never good enough carried right into
adulthood it was very very destructive
to everyone around me and even today by
the way too by the way when we get
together with my family even today there
is discussion about whether I threw the
cake out the window or not and the power
started and this is what's happened to
my mind I start thinking did I really
see that monkey or did I I don't even
know after a while which is sort of
interesting so anyway that's a very long
story but that's it all right that is a
great story yeah I want to hear the
monkeys version of that story that's
some point I'll track that monkey down
that'll be really awkward podcast how
did your parents or how did your family
end up going to Sierra Leone of all
places
my dad got attacked in the middle of the
night you know my parents are the
mildest two meekest mannered Asians you
can possibly meet my dad's an accountant
and you know he never like even now when
I travel nomads in Botswana or Namibia
or Indonesia or Colorado Aspen the same
advice don't talk to strangers be
careful what you eat you know like all
like it's the same kind of like me
careful advice but they had this one
gigantic moment of courage which I still
don't understand because even today
would yeah massive deal to do but these
these Asians who never have left the
country decided to pick pick up their
five-year-old in one-year-old and over
weekend decide that the country was
getting politically really bad and with
two suitcases and only the jewelry my
mother had just
and the only place they my dad had a job
offer was in Sierra Leone as an
accountant for a forestry company later
on his career just took off and he did
great but it just was this unbelievable
thing and not just the cap but not
Freetown like this is like where Ebola
was like recently right I mean this is
where there's a 30-year civil war in
Sierra Leone we didn't just go to the
capital we went 200 miles in the
interior and lived in like a tree house
with quite literally monkeys obviously
around us and I don't get that I still
ask them then they're like yeah you know
we just like we didn't have a choice you
know we just just like the two lotteries
you win you know the parents you have
that's one lottery you don't get picked
that I won that one the country of your
birth is the second lottery I sort of
snuck into that one but those are the
two things
and Steve's completely right you know
all of the other things in your life
tend not to matter as much as those two
lotteries that you get so let's talk
about the factors or maybe if you could
describe for us how you ended up in
science and then conservation yeah sure
um look you know I always loved nature I
loved animals I think all kids loved
nature and love things that move and as
you get older it kind of gets beaten out
of you right you just get stopped
encouraging to do that but my parents
just let me do that because the only
thing that was sort of around me and I
fooled them for a long time thinking I
was sort of in pre-med and kind of went
further and further into that sort of
realm until eventually very late in my
sort of mat I got had my master's and
just getting into my PhD I sort of
realized that there's actually a career
that was actually open to Asians in
thinking about the environment and
thinking about conservation and thinking
about actually saving the planet that
you could actually do that respectively
so for most of your life and be okay
with it it took a lot of convincing for
that bigger family to sort of get that
you know once I got my PhD I tell a
story all that
I went back to Sri Lanka and my
grandmother I overheard her telling her
friend who's like across the wall like
kind of leans over and they have this
conversation my grandson is back he's a
doctor now but not the kind of saves
people and my grout gosh you have to add
that right and I started thinking about
it and I'm like really isn't that what
we're actually trying to do because
ultimately it's all connected young
people need nature to thrive and that is
one virtuous cycle but it was a fooling
game and I bet many many people who
follow their pouring her passion you
know she the try to find their way
do a lot of sort of fooling around and
fooling of other people fooling of
social circles I was just lucky lucky
lucky enough that that that there was
enough there and I finally realized that
I could actually do this what was the
triggering event like you were getting
at the time so your masters and PhD were
in what uh sorry where were they oh the
fields what was the what was the
concentration I mean it was you know it
was biology for my masters and then
wildlife and genetics for my PhD and was
there a conversation or a book or
something that proved to you the
conservation could be a path you could
embrace or was it you know honestly I I
wish there was something like more epic
on that there I mean I think there were
two moments in my life where I made
these big leaps the first was coming to
America deciding that I wanted to be
here for like graduate school or like my
my higher education and that was because
of Bruce Springsteen kid you not this is
a kid you not that's how we picked
colleges back then right because you
didn't have like I didn't have like well
I didn't have the Internet I definitely
didn't have any way of knowing like why
America would make sense for me I'd very
little concept of America but someone
gave me that Nebraska album and I
remember looking at the cover of that
album and something about that cover and
something about the that the songs in
that and the last song on that album and
it just made you want to think of sort
of endless possibilities and sort of
wide open spaces and I always felt
confined in my life confined by society
or by whatever I was always a stranger
in a strange land
no matter where we move because we moved
around a lot throughout Africa and
sometimes in Dasia
and I just felt that that was a big leap
like taking this sort of debt to come to
America and then the second one I think
had more to do with I had an amazing
advisor a guy named Michael sulla he was
like the father of conservation biology
you really find that word and he put it
on the map and you know 20 years ago he
was the guy and I was lucky enough to
work with him
I just cold called him and sort of
pestered him until he took me on as do
then I think that made me realize there
was a path that so you mentioned this
professor could you remind me of his
last name the pronunciation shoe lane
and so you I leave it there now I've
read that he told you your job as a
graduate student was to train yourself
as critical thinker I believe maybe
that's the internet lying to me again
but no so what was true was like so I
was eager to say things like you thought
that that's what you did and you know I
wanted to go save Waialae and he said no
right right now your job is to just do a
really good piece of science it's
actually good advice I do a really hard
piece of work so that you'd own it and
you'd know that once in your life you
could do that
and this time enough later to save
things he tells me now that he might not
have said that advice today but at that
time it made an impression on me and
that's sort of what I did
why wouldn't he give that advice today
did he explain I think I think he is so
distraught about what has happened in
the last 20 or 30 years to our planet
and and so am i and I think we are
really impatient and I keep waiting for
other people to see something that I
have seen and very very few people
around me somehow seem to have that gene
turned on and I think that impatience at
what what sort of makes this sometimes
be irrational but other times just feel
desperate so the the intention just to
take a step back so you guys have the
meta context here what are we doing
that's that's the question of the
evening so I initially I was like you
know it'd be really fun is to have you
know Steve Case come up who's in the
book and ask him questions that aren't
in the book
and then to have someone you come up and
ask the questions that are in the book
but then of course we get the birthday
cake and the monkey and we're off on a
completely different landscape so I'm
gonna bounce around between questions
that I'm dying to ask but then the
questions that I feel like would be fun
to sprinkle throughout so there's gonna
be very little connective tissue it's
can be like the worst edited movie
you've ever seen what purchase of $100
or less has most positively impacted
your life in recent memory that's a
really hard question for me because I
don't buy a lot of stuff I'm a total
snob when it comes to like the stuff I
own and the reason for that is because I
travel incessantly and when I travel I
just have one bag and I have to take it
everything I own has to do like double
duty and so I'm very very very picky
about like either simplifying or just
taking exactly what I like so I can't
think of something really easy that
comes to mind under 100 bucks they could
just name ice breaker underwear so ice
breaker is a great company they produce
amazing stuff all out of merino wool in
a while yeah new zealand-based company I
think you and I both know the founder
and Jeremy moon and I like his personal
ethos and his stuff works I don't get
paid by this company anything like that
but that's probably the last under
hundred dollar purchase I made that I
love do you have a go-to bag you
mentioned you have one bag have you
vetted a lot of bad yeah so I used to
love this Victoria Knox bag they don't
make it anymore see the problem with
just kills you right it really kills you
like you just figure out that there's
something that works really well and
then they go and change it like shoes
like athletic shoes oh my god did they
change it and there's a whole race to
change it fast so this is really a hard
question because I now use a Tumi bag
and I like it because I like the four
wheels I also like the sturdiness of
that bag it's heavy that's the downside
on it
all right but I'm getting older so I
can't really know these things on my
back anymore time this is very specific
or wheel to me back do you have do you
have a protocol for surviving or
maintaining your sanity and health for
really long flights like that flight
from Botswana where I am bushed you know
with this invitation is there anything
specially doing I know friends who carry
saline misters for their noses or wrap
their heads and all sorts of weird
contraptions to block out sound and
light or you just go out and you're done
no you know I try to be like as
comfortable as I possibly can during the
flight I mean it's just the usual stuff
I try to get myself on the new time zone
fast and very strictly about how when I
drink coffee or anything like coffee or
tea very strategic by the timing on that
I tend to fast a little bit on flights I
don't eat a lot just because I can catch
up later and it always makes me feel a
little better I guess that's sort of it
like sometimes you get like it depends
it really like I did this flight and
I'll be absolutely honest with you I fly
so much that sometimes I'm flying in
business class specific very very long
flights when I have to like gland there
and get into meetings sometimes I find
economy I did this very long flight from
Sydney to Johannesburg and I'm in the
back of an old 747 middle seat
with these two very nice but large some
more in gentleman by the side of it yes
the plane hadn't even really taken off
they both fell asleep and their hands
kept falling into my lap and put it and
you know that kind of flight you just
okay you just have to just completely do
this mind shift so what you do so I
stripped all my stuff off got really
like into like I you know like you know
my jeans and a t-shirt you know sort of
curled out made my little space and then
started playing this game so all you
have to do is think about what worse
form of transportation you could be
stuck in in that moment
so you just have to think well this
could be a you know Mombasa - you know
like Kampala you know truck draw arrive
right now in the in the back of like a
local bus you know and you'd like oh my
god this would be so much better than
that like I could like order food and
you get drinks and I mean like you could
just infinitely infinitely better
infinitely better so that's the trick
like I once had to spend an entire month
in a very small cabin on a boat no
windows it's a research vessel I'm stuck
in there with another roommate tiny for
a month and I and we had food literally
cans of food under our bed that's how
small the whole but I kept thinking this
is like a sleeper suite on Singapore
Airlines like $20,000 ticket right now
because I can sleep this is a shower
like I can walk around and it just makes
you feel so much better so that's the
trick with distance anytime the space
constraint just think of what's worse
and then just mind it worked it
sounds like a fantastic trick I'm still
thinking about the the thick Samoan
hands landing in there flap if you were
to we were talking about one of your
mentors and the advice he gave you if
you were to have the opportunity to
teach say give you three options a ninth
grade class college freshman class or
college senior class you choose one of
those three and to teach a seminar or
class of your choosing what age would
you choose and what would you teach you
have a semester so tell me again how old
people have at ninth grade eighth grade
it's 15 14 15 notes a 14 probably you
know I probably teach that Freshman
Seminar class freshman college freshman
college because I think I have relatable
experiences that I can translate to that
group and it's still early enough for
their trajectory to make a big
difference so that's probably why I
picked that group and what would I teach
yeah go with the class be and it doesn't
have to be
there's no prereq there's no like it be
like how to get done
or like this is a good this is a good
subject it's like it's like so much
stuff that we learned in college is
wasted if you just think about the vast
amounts of stuff that they taught us
that we never ever actually use like
that so I would love to look I would
probably teach a class and like being
really honest because I do teach at
university so it'd probably be something
about biology and something about the
environment right so chances are it
would be in that thing might be a it
might be a class in communication so
because I've done like enough television
work and stuff like that to be able to
do that legitimately so but or
storytelling but I would probably teach
a class in biology but if I really could
get away with it I would do something
like you know like all the things you
wish you'd known getting into this or
how to organize your life to get stuff
done
you know and be kind of in that vein if
I think just basically take some of your
books crib it agitate it so I want to
ask both about the getting done
Freshman Seminar no no but let's just as
a thought exercise if it were instead
just so you don't have to think about
the entire semester if it were just a
three to four hour seminar and it what
would be some of the key principles or
strategies or anything that you would
want to hammer home you're getting me
after a really long fight so it's my
break we get also by sometime by asking
you what you would teach in a
storytelling class or getting corrected
yeah I could do you see so the what was
the question is the question was if you
have a three to four hour seminar on
getting done yeah what are some of
the any of the key messages or
strategies or anything that you would
emphasize so because you get a lot done
I mean I've observed how much you do and
it boggles my mind I don't know how you
yes so so
the look you know there's some some of
the principles that you'd probably want
to try to get into is you know dealing
with focus right so this is a major
challenge especially for younger younger
people and it's not getting any better
and I have the ability right and it's
not because I have some magical ability
it's because just practice it intensely
focusing on one thing for a few seconds
or for a few minutes and I think that
ability to intensely focus on something
and not be distracted from anything else
is a very useful habit to have and so
I'm very good at one like when you're
one-on-one you can be one-on-one you can
be very focused I think that's true for
storytelling I think that's true for
really getting information out of people
and I think helping people focusing on
one thing and then switching to another
so it's a serial focus is a very very
useful practice I think that you know we
waste enormous amounts of time
pretending to work and we can just sort
of get rid of that whole thing I think
we I think we're not honest with
ourselves about what we're really good
at and what we're not good at and you in
a very early success to life as being
absolutely brutally honest at what
you're not good at and you can
compensate for it to some ways but just
don't like you ask people so what do you
think you're good at and they'll sort of
tell you their resume or they'll recite
you that sort of and that's not
particularly useful I'll tell them about
the things that I wish I had done I
think every student that going through
should should take a class in ethics I
think every student going through should
take a class on communications and
storytelling I think every student who
goes through should think about how
during their four year or three whatever
their college term is spending a little
time working on something that is
completely unrelated to their primary
area of interest that was probably the
best thing I ever did when I was going
through the American education system is
that during the summers I was restricted
on what jobs I could do because I was
student ID go and work at the World Bank
and for a biologist to be walking around
the World Bank was a very strange thing
at the time and it was unbelievably
useful to me it was like the most useful
thing I did really why was it useful
because it just put me in touch with a
whole bunch of people who were
completely unlike me and who would think
about the world in a completely
different terms I'd go in there and be
like you must be an economist I'm like
no I'm a wildlife biologist and they'd
be like wow that's crazy what are you
doing here
and but we but I just started realizing
how they worked and how a whole
different set of rules apply how a whole
another institution was working on
problems you know and just it just
opened my eyes it just opened my the
easiest thing would have been for me to
go work for a non-profit like the one I
work for now
conservation says on the nature cancer I
didn't do that I really particularly
went and got jobs in areas that had
nothing nothing to do with my primary
area of interest just to see what it
looked like and the best the funnest
things in the world are all on those
angles right when you can bring to
different fields together there's
there's so much gold in those angles you
do that all the time actually and and
I've really you know learning how to
exploit that is often your little trick
to getting a head start
it makes me think also of a career
advice that I've heard from both Scott
Adams creator of Dilbert and also Marc
Andreessen in different senses but
they've said this is more scott adams
and his writing that there are different
ways to quote unquote
succeed one is you can try to be say top
1% of 1% like a Michael Jordan in one
skill that's really really really really
difficult the other approach is that you
could be say in the top 10% in to
typically uncombined areas right so you
have scott adams who would say himself
he's not the best artist he's not the
best comedian but he's unusually good at
combining both of those things and in
the world of business it could be saying
a jd+ computer science or softer skills
and I've heard Warren Buffett talk about
his best-ever and
being I believe it was Toastmasters or
some equivalent public speaking course
because you layer that on top of almost
anything and it automatically puts you
in a position to have a really unfair
advantage so story telling you were kind
enough we were trading some notes before
this and you mentioned storytelling so
this is one thing I highlighted of notes
that you sent to me which was
storytelling is one way to rule the
world and another friend of mine has
been on the podcast Chris Sacca
who's just an incredible investor
hilarious guy but the he originally
trained to be lawyer and he was beaten
soundly at one point by this guy who got
up after Chris had presented all of his
spreadsheets and all the data and some
guy got up I think it was in Arkansas or
Texas or somewhere names like well you
know you can't lead a horse to water if
something you just start speaking in
like five or six different parables and
completely kicked Chris's ass and so
Chris concluded that stories beat
spreadsheets
it's how have you developed your ability
to tell stories or how would you
recommend people develop perhaps books
tools practices the ability to tell
better stories because I think it's as
you've said so so so powerful right so I
really agree with what you just said and
I think I think storytelling is one
really powerful way to kind of rule the
world and a lot of people that we kind
of look up to and think about like you
know from Einstein to Elon Musk to Steve
Jobs they were really powerful
storytellers in their own way right so
they had this ability through words or
through images to really convince you
that you could do something that no one
else could could to think about and that
just that mind shift that they created
propelled you along with their vision
and all of a sudden you were doing it so
and you can you can absolutely learn
those skills you can actually get better
at it so when I was in high school I was
painfully shy like painfully shy well
very thick glass at long
I did get beat up all the time it was it
was I went to school for my high school
I went to school there was like Hogwarts
without any of the magic and it was
really the first time but I had a break
and the break was this is such a funny
break so I was sent to boarding school
in England this is in England for a year
and the break was that we had a debate
team which is quite good and it would go
up against like Eton and all the other
schools like that and the kid who was
supposed to be like the alt the main kid
for this debate team you know got ill
and they suggested that I fill that role
and I did and you know I really had to
the first time where I did this you know
they make fun of my accent because I had
a bit of an accent I didn't actually
have much of an accent but in their
minds I had a very strong Asian accent
and what I did was I started the debate
with that very very strong I just over
emphasized everyone laughed at me I
laughed at myself I got over it
and I moved on it's not a big deal to do
today but when you're 14 or 15 it feels
big and scary and really hard to do and
I realized that there was power in that
by the way we went all the way the
finals and this kit then got well and
then they kicked me off the team
and then this kid actually lost not
saying anything here but is exactly
literally I like three debates three
rounds like we would go doing fine the
team was doing great okay
he had chickenpox and then he was out of
quarantine so he could come back on the
team and then I was off okay so you
can't you can't practice you get better
so I practice and I think about it I
think about how people tell stories
I even Tim like you look at Tim you open
that first couple of pages he talks that
little story that he puts in there about
you know you know what he was grappling
with in his college days
it immediately captivates you you just
immediately want to know more and read
more right so there's real power there
and you can develop and get better at it
so what are some of the ways in which
you can do this so you have to be
genuinely interested in the stories
you're telling can't fake that
like if you're interviewing someone you
got to be actually a fan of that person
maybe if you're not a fan of that topic
or that person or not genuinely
interested it's just not gonna work
right you got to own that story it's
gonna be all you can't Bluff the story
it can't kind of lie about it you can
learn a story and repeat someone else's
story but you really have to own it in
like a deep deep sense of it you have to
know when to stop you have to know when
to you know the message is also
important right so there's something I
often say it gets not just the story but
it's also the kind of stories you tell
and they have to be true to who you are
as a as a storyteller so look this I'm
not a professional like I teaching
people how to tell stories I I can't do
that professionally I know I do it you
know I practice it I got it from my
parents I think it's a wonderful craft
to think about read books and read books
and figure out what piece of that is
really catching your heart it always
starts with the heart it always come
from places like commonality and
laughter and love or or pain or
something from the heart before you can
engage the mind and that those sorts of
stories always tend to win so underscore
something you said and then I want to
ask about this very very clear smirk
that came on your face when you just
said something a second ago but I think
the going for the heart or noticing what
captures the heart applies to questions
too so for instance Cal fuss Minh
who was one of the main writers of the
what I learned column and Esquire for a
long long long time I want to say 10
plus years interviewed Gorbachev and all
these people routinely would get told
right before an interview yeah this
hour-long interview you know have five
minutes and so you would have to hook
someone like Gorby into continuing to
talk and you'd think about his questions
then he'd say you know tell me about
when your father left for war and was
there any particular lesson he taught
you and he would go for the emotion
first and that would then allow him to
get to the heavier questions later so I
think that it applies to not only the
telling of stories but the asking the
eliciting of stories and good
storytelling is that right so in a good
story a really phenomenal story is one
where you actually are having this
relationship with the audience and it's
a two-way story when people do that
magically you're at a whole other kind
of level of it and like when you talk
about how you organize your questions
you know you know it sounds just so
simple like okay he's got a bunch of
questioning that there's so much thought
going into it because you're actually
engaging a story you're doing it in that
way so that you can get the whole thing
kind of coming out right yeah absolutely
and that the piece that I wanted to ask
about it maybe it was just because you
enjoy smiling and do it so well but you
said you have to know when to stop and
then you may think you have this big
grin on your face
yeah maybe that was just me noticing
something that wasn't there but what's
what's behind knowing when to stop or
like what's the opposite what does that
look like just telling a long story that
goes on too long so the best
storytellers leave you wanting to hear
more best comedians just absolutely we
leave you wanting to hear more there's a
real art to that you can't give it all
away you have to leave the audience
saying I wanted to help like tell me
more like and and that's really
important about knowing when to be able
to stop and you can over explain things
many many ways I'm I'm really enough
particular today by the ways I'm done am
i apologizing a little bit for that but
that's a really important skill to know
like when does that story end and don't
bury the punchline you know like you
know like so many times it's like
there's a whole wind-up way I'm gonna
tell you now a story about a monkey that
stole Mike don't do that just go right
into it because you have them at the
first minute and then every minute after
that you're gonna start losing audience
shares so you want to get it fast and
get right into into it as fast as you
can so I want to talk about by the way
can I tell you one thing about that just
the yes of course stuff so you know when
I was talking about the message in the
message about owning a story go go do
this when you get a chance and you get
home you know that song respect
everything re s PCT you know that song
right yeah so who sang that already the
frankly and everyone knows who read the
fine print everyone can like hum it
right now if I played it too you'd know
in the heartbeat she's not the one who's
actually sang it it's actually done by
Otis Redding same words same song very
different meaning the song is really
like exact opposite of what everything
makes that song to be Otis Redding song
it's like you know I'm working all day
woman and I'm like putting food on the
table for you and like when I
come home I'm so sorry I said that uh
when I come home all I want is just like
some goddamn respect right that's this
song never made it big but Otis Redding
was a big singer by then it's decent
song decent blues song she owned it she
completely same words but just the way
she put that story together her complete
ownership of it and who'll forget that
her spelling of that just makes her like
makes her the one who remembers it and
later on in life
Otis actually sort of kind of complained
slightly about about her like taking the
song and making it so huge and no one
remembers that he's the one who recorded
it and sang it and performed it for at
least two years before she came along so
just you want to hear seek two stories
same story told in different ways listen
to those two songs that's amazing I have
no idea
I want to talk about some of the stories
and stories may not be the right word
but narratives that have stuck with you
and I'm going to prompt it with a
and I can certainly cheat a little bit
in prompt but what is the book or books
you've given the most as a gift and why
or books that have influenced you yeah
we Tim and I've talked about this a
little bit so for me books are like all
about the moment and the emotion that I
am in and the person I'm giving it to it
is in and so I can't tell you that
there's one book that has predominated
how I give because I love books and I'd
love to give books and I carry books
around and even today I brought two
books for you to autograph that I'm
giving away right so there's an act of
giving and and that and that and the
book is a wonderful way to convey
something to to another person books
that I've loved giving away Norman
Maclean's river runs through it I read
that book in so many different ways and
so many pieces it totally influenced my
life in terms of fly-fishing and finding
sort of magic and words and that quiet
space you also wrote that book when he
was 71 years old kind of really the only
big book you wrote
that's 71 and you think about all this
about like creative genius
being in the young and all that you get
older you start appreciating that if
Norman could do it at 71 maybe I could
do it like you know not quite at 71 yet
another book I really liked more recent
book is standing with crystals team of
teams completely different reasons just
a really clever smart book about how to
organize businesses and enterprises for
today's world and he takes us in
experience from the Army in in
Afghanistan and sort of you know and
brings it over to sort of them to your
life or my life and makes it kind of
relevant and meaningful I found it very
influential I I've given away a quite a
few copies of James Nestor's book the
deep which you might have read right
even read this I haven't read that book
is pretty damn good it's about it's
about free diving which I knew nothing
about and that was a that was one of my
birthday things that was like two years
ago so I thought I'll try this free
diving thing because I read Nestor's
book and it's amazing the physiology of
the human body and what it can do is
amazing so I read this book it's about
free diving a very scary very sort of
can be a very dangerous sport but
awesome
using sport because it completely
changes the way you think about your
body and what you're capable of and I
thought what right this is this book
inspired me I'm gonna go try and take a
lesson in free done so I went to Hawaii
around my birthday and I took a lesson
from our very very good you want to do
this with someone very very good and I
did and this woman Shelly Eisenberg
who's my teacher for the day you know
basically look this is what she did
within three hours I could hold my
breath for like maybe 45 seconds maybe a
minute like if I tried within three
hours three hours just by doing
exercises with me she had me at two
minutes ten seconds that floored me
it'd be like saying how fast can you run
I'd be like okay I can do like a
9-minute mile and you saying well give
me three hours and I get you down to
like a six minute like you just couldn't
do that and that floored me and she's
like yeah like let's keep going and like
sure enough you know you're doing three
minutes doing three minutes within 24
hours under yoga true-story
can do it everyone in here can do that
too that's why that book was so kind of
mentally transformative I feel obligated
as the person who certainly not a doctor
and you've heard this before I don't
play when on the internet but you have
to be very very careful with this type
of training good so do not do take the
DIY approach I know people I know people
who have died and I know people who have
come very close to dying from shallow
water blackouts and when you depending
on the technique if you blow off a lot
of co2
you won't sense that you're going to
black out before you black out you're
fine and then you're blacked out but you
don't really want to have happen in any
amount of water right you could Jimi
Hendrix yourself or it could be in a
thousand feet of water same outcome so
be very very careful
only with supervision but it is
fascinating yeah I mean to Navy SEALs
drowned in a training exercise in San
Diego like two years ago
you know just the two of them just
trying this out and and breaking the
rules without the number one thing with
this is which is like you're doing it
with a buddy who can do this better than
you can and and and she goes and you
definitely want to do this and that's
why I didn't just try this yeah read his
book then I went to got
one of the best teachers and I spent
time with her and that's why I think
it's an things billboards let's talk
about them if you could have a giant
billboard anywhere with anything on it
no billboard with a message you get out
to millions or billions of people what
would it say and why I'm gonna take an
easy one out there I'm gonna use one of
the slogans that we at Conservation
International used in some ways which I
would probably say something like either
people need nature that's not obvious
now I'd say nature's speaking I might
say nature's screamin and I'd like to
put those outside every place where
there's like this quote-unquote natural
disaster which is usually human disaster
that was exacerbated by just not
listening to nature that's what I do and
I'd always influenced by like you drive
across this country you see these signs
for like religious purposes right like
so so in Saudia t will do this to you or
not do this to you only you believe and
I was taught well why don't we put that
same kind of effort into putting
billboards up it says nature's screaming
on H is speaking when are we gonna
listen to something like that so that's
probably what I really want you and this
isn't just professional courtesy so we
can talk about the work you're doing
conservation and the the state of
progressive destruction of our natural
habitats and surroundings causes me a
lot of anxiety personally in part
because I feel like for instance study
comes out on metabolism and they're a
bunch of conflicting headlines and
things are poorly interpreted by certain
media I can parse it i can go to pubmed
i can figure out what's what but in the
world of conservation or trying to do
the right thing I sometimes feel lost in
the sense that I attempt to do the right
thing when I perceive it to be the right
thing and then I find out oh that
type of wild caught fish or farmed fish
is exactly the opposite of what I should
be doing or whatever it might be
what are
you can have a lot of people listening
to this people in this room then people
on the podcast what are some of if
people want to think more precisely
about this and feel like they can take
proactive steps what are some of the
most common misconceptions about
conservation or what's a smart way to
just approach thinking about it right so
the first thing I would say is don't let
perfection and trying to find the silver
bullet keep you out of the game so we
were both recently at at summit in Los
Angeles and you know I heard people talk
about philanthropy and giving and
wanting to find like the most perfect
way to give and I was sort of struck by
how many people around me all nodding
and I just think to myself
like really like yeah okay I want to
make sure my dollar goes the farthest as
well there's so many other things in
life which we waste all the time and why
this one we want perfection so you know
when I when someone says to me like tell
me the one thing I can do to change the
planet like guess what there isn't so
there's lots of things and it's messy
you're not always gonna get it right and
is it better to drink out a ceramic cup
that you have to wash in hot water or a
you know a Styrofoam cup those are
important questions for you to think
about but ultimately they shouldn't stop
you from from getting engaged so the
truth of the matter is very very very
few people are actually engaged in like
trying to care about the fate of our
planet fate of where we live and our
kids lives and I just want to get more
people in it and I think if more in it
then absolutely we'll come up with more
home solutions but it shouldn't stop you
from getting in it so that's like my
first thing I would say if you want to
make some small changes in your life
like what you eat and how you cook it
makes a huge difference like it's
probably the one thing that you could do
so being thoughtful like
whether it's farm caught or wha even
that's a useful question to think about
and try to get at least the best halfway
there
and I can answer that for you like
there's like seafood watch at the
Monterey Bay Aquarium puts out gives you
a reasonable pathway but how you cook
and how you waste food like wasting food
is a big big deal like your energy
output on those it's like completely
outweighs what car you drive or anything
like that right so that's just something
simple you can do you know get engaged
in the political system I think it
really does matter I I you know you know
I mean it really does matter right so
there was this kind of crazy decision
very recently on on wanting to at this
moment in time but all these crises are
going on the planet on overturning the
ban on importing elephant heads from
from trophy hunting from Zimbabwe and
Zambia like that actually somehow became
a priority for the administration like
all of a sudden like we're gonna like
overturn the ban so that any hunter who
goes to Zimbabwe or Zambia and shoots an
elephant and bring the ivory and they
head into the country like why is that
all of a sudden the thing to do and
people really got upset about it and
believenot kind of did change something
at least for now
there's been a reversal of that decision
so the administration has decided to
like wait on that for a while so make
your voices heard it's important that
you make your voices heard and don't sit
this out are there any other resources
that you would suggest people look to
like seafood watch or any other websites
where people could find simple things
they might not think of like this lower
shipping to make an impact I mean if
just assuming these people are busy
professionals with high demands on their
time we're going to suggest they look
okay so now and without being totally
self-serving so I will say like some my
own organization conservation org decent
website you'll find lots of ways in
which you can be engaged the nature
conservancy nature
org decent website lots of ways you can
get engaged environmental defense fund
they do a lot of great work particularly
in the United States around climate
world Resource Institute gives you the
macro picture they great graphics great
infographics gives you sort of the macro
picture I did a series recently on box
your ex with the University of
California called climate labs which is
just these eight minute very short
digestible little videos on something
like food waste slightly reverent
slightly counterintuitive simple ways in
which you can either get engaged or make
a change in your life you can have an
impact and so we took a bunch of
different topics like shipping and and
did these short videos on it's called
climate labs on box so those are sort of
things that come quickly to mind but
here's the most important thing
seriously I really mean this we really
are on a race to save the planet I
really really believe this you know
here's the thing
we're the only generation who actually
has some foresight like think about this
in the entire history of humanity we had
to like rely on like crystal balls and
like you know like I don't know like
either a burning bush right sitting
where we are to give us a glimpse to
give us a glimpse of where we're heading
and now we actually have some data with
the first generation in human history to
see the entire Emmett John Glenn before
I passed away amazing guy makes America
just American to go around planets see
the whole thing I asked him he said yeah
it blew me away I never thought we could
see the whole planet all at once like if
you were standing on a flat earth you
know if you're standing on the unsee
show you see about seven miles after
that the horizon dips away and as long
as humans have been around we've been
climbing tall and taller mountains
towers trees to be able to see what's
over the horizon what we're looking for
we're thinking about a lion that's over
the horizon and my bite is are looking
for opportunity now in our generation we
can see the whole thing and only that
we're also mostly all connected there is
no reason for us not to act right now
and believe me that window is small
and if we don't do it I swear future
generation will look back and said what
a waste you had that opportunity when
the opportunity cost was actually
relatively cheap the price of
conservation will never get cheaper in
the future it's cheap as it's gonna get
now it'll only get more expensive so not
acting now is crazy and that's what
people who've done The Giving Pledge
like takes decays and others I so
applaud that because they're not just
saying we're gonna leave this we would
you know leave this for future
generation deal with they're saying
we're gonna deal with it now because
right now is probably cheapest to be
able to deal with it
so oh it's just a few more questions and
then we'll do some audience and then
we'll head off to tequila shots whatever
comes next but I really want to ask you
what you found helpful for training
humans to think more long-term because
it strikes me that if you look at
history and you don't have to go very
far back but you certainly could that
we've amol we've evolved for millions of
years effectively to survive until
puberty have sex and procreate that's
basically it I mean that's Darwinism at
work and people will act in there in
intensely I mean worst of interests long
term for short term gain how do you
train people to think more in long
longer term time horizons and in ways
that are more communal and not
individual it's it seems like a very
tough task but a very very very
important one what are some of the most
effective learnings or lessons that
you've had with that so III I'm I don't
know that's the truth of the answer I
don't know how to fundamentally beat
evolutionary biology it is so hardwired
into us the people who do and do it
rationally so you like look at like you
know what Charlie Munger says right it
says look we basically our investment
technology eek you know with that he and
Buffett use it's just don't do anything
stupid over the long run pretty much
that basically says that right it's it's
surprisingly simple but incredibly hard
to follow yeah incredibly hard to follow
and the people who do it tend to be sort
of investors and others who sort of
faithfully follow a system but even they
get spooked as we've seen many many
times over right so it's very difficult
to beat it so I'm not trying to do that
I'm just trying to figure out how I can
make you changing your life for the
betterment of the planet in your own end
lightin self-interest and the better I
can do that and tell you that it's
actually gonna make your life better now
now now now
not even you kids but your life the
better chance I have of promoting change
the interesting thing is it doesn't have
to be rational because we do so many
things that are completely irrational
and so it doesn't have to be rational it
it can be very emotional and it has to
be about your own enlightened
self-interest it can't be about the
future so I think at some point we'll
have to do around to but look at that
that's just my like I'm stuck and any
help you have and want to throw it my
way my way will take it but I'm actually
stuck because I know much better
communicator than I am and far smarter
people than I am in my field was we're
basically stuck as well well to that
point I mean the minute my next question
is going to be what ask would you have
of people listening is there anything
that you're looking for any particular
type of help or next steps that people
you would like to see people take
because you have you have a lot of
people listening people in all different
walks of life different sectors every
possible place imaginable what would you
like them to do or consider so the most
important thing you could do for me or
for a so for this cause is to be a
messenger it really is quite simply that
because the people who are more likely
to listen are people like yourself
they're more likely citizen
send message coming from you than if it
came from me and that's really proof
like so they strongly believe like I
strongly believe in that right so the
messenger matters as much as the message
you can reach audience that I could
never reach so being that messenger to
carry that message into your community
into your church a synagogue your place
of worship your school your community
your family is far far more useful than
me trying to just get my voice to be
bigger and bigger and bigger thank you
and where can people say hello to you on
social or learn more about what you're
up to
is Twitter the best place is Twitter the
best place Twitter is a good place
Facebook is also really good because it
allows the longer conversation to just
sort of occur so you know I can easily
be found as M sanjayan and some on
Facebook and that's a good place to also
engage
I mean Twitter is fine too mm-hmm then
Conservation Network
yeah and conservation dogs so I you know
I think our website and our social media
platform is a great place to engage
perfect so we'll simply put a DC
audience but I think also our global
audience this is this is I think a good
place to grab just a few questions then
we can we can close up and have some
have some tequila give George Clooney a
few hundred million more dollars if
anybody has a custom ego story what a
story by the way well he's thinking
about that I one of the book I want to
mention to you guys especially for this
town is a book called destiny of the
Republic by Candice Maillard fantastic
books is a great author and she talked
about President Garfield and being shot
and how his life could have been saved
if they'd only listened to the surgeon
who gave them the advice but he was sort
of ignored because he was this black
surgeon in the Union Army and instead
they took another route and it's just an
a fascinating story about race and
technology at the cusp of a really
important moment in our nation but a
president that very few people had heard
about but who if he had survived would
completely changed the course of our
country probably for the better so this
this is a question from Bill from Long
Island it's addressed to me but I'm
gonna ask you since I've talked at
nauseam about my mornings what does the
first 60 to 90 seconds of your day look
like I want to modify this but but he's
asking what what do you do to jumpstart
the first waking moments do you have any
morning rituals or routines that are
consistent for you anything you do in
the first coffee yeah to jump start my
day or just anything that you do as part
of your routine in the mornings yes so
you know I
often put like the toughest things I
need to deal with and the most creative
things early in the morning it's just as
simple as that
I tend not to I tend not to check my
email until I'm actually starting work
that's just something I did my work
they're just really cluttered the mind
and what what so what happens with email
is especially for my company because
it's a global organization so I get
emails in the middle of the night and so
they pile out and so if I find out that
if I if I open my day by checking email
I get diverted into all these other
small things that I am very bad at
saying no to so I kind of ruined the
rest that day and rather I want to set
my agenda then look at it and deal with
the ones I can deal with and ignore the
others this is a question from it's
either Eric or Erin I'm not quite sure
who's your most recent mentor and what
does that person taught you and I mean
we could make that if you have an answer
for that great otherwise we could we
could modify it to just be what is a
recent lesson that you've learned or in
the site so you know that's a good one
because it kind of talked Hawkins back
to you know tribal mentor so one of the
things that I did that I found very very
useful in my life and I think for many
of you you could apply to is that some
years ago I created a personal board so
a group of individuals who would
personally spend a little bit of time
vesting in me and my success and I
didn't do this because some grandiose
notion of who I was but it struck me
that whenever you wanted like letters of
reference when you go for a job you
always didn't have to like sort of
scramble around and try to catch up to
people who you haven't spoken to for a
long time and hope they'll give you this
letter and they really don't know you by
that point and life has sort of gone by
and what happened if I had a group of
say five individuals that I would pick
and I would make a promise that I've
never solicited them for money which
I've I've kept up even though some now
do give to CI but that's not the purpose
they don't belong to my organization
they're not my board for my organization
they're my personal board and the great
people and
would just say to them listen can you do
this for me I'll meet with you two maybe
three times a week we'll have coffee or
lunch two three times a week start two
or three times a year okay
[Laughter]
and we'll you know we'll just have a
little you know conversation and a catch
up and I can just occasionally ping you
for guidance that has been incredibly
incredibly useful I picked some great
people you might know some of them but
they it's been very very helpful okay so
I want to I want to dig into this cuz
this is really interesting so your
personal board by the way they all said
yes okay well yeah but how can we not
get into this now I want to mention just
as a side note because people might find
this helpful something that I found very
helpful from Chris Fussel who
co-authored team of teams with Stan
McChrystal and he was Stan's
aide-de-camp for quite a long time in
JSOC and advice that he was given was it
at all times you want to surround
yourself with at least three people
someone who is doing an excellent job of
what you hope to be doing say a few
years from now someone who is doing a
better job than you are in some capacity
at what you're doing now and then
somebody who is doing something you used
to do but is doing it much better than
you did and that was how he ended up
seeking out people to surround himself
with how did you choose since they all
said yes I guess you reached out to five
or six people right or how did you
choose those people what were the
criteria you know I look I wanted people
I I respected so that was sort of
important to me they had that to be
people I really should have respected I
wanted people who were not in my field
because I had plenty of colleagues in my
field I wanted people so so I'll just
give you some I'll give you some names I
don't think it matters that much Tom
tyranny the bridge span he's also the
chairman of the Nature Conservancy now
really smart guy you know he kind of
gets how businesses should organize he
he's just this he coached me on how to
get the CEO job for Conservation
International and the tips he gave me
were incredibly valuable like incredible
I'd never realized that you could
actually coach your way into a job and
that guy really helped me do that so
that was one Paula kerger should to see
the president of PBS amazing woman
very unusual she was a development staff
so she asked people for money and then
roast the ranks and ended up running PBS
she also is across the road from my
office so it's kind of easy to sometimes
see her really smart very thoughtful
wonderfully kind generous person ganon
set diamond crosspoint venture partners
so on his company's also racecar driver
that guy interviews CEOs for a living so
his whole job is about interviewing CEOs
and deciding which ones he wants to bet
on as a be as a venture capital guy
really useful for me as I'm thinking
about what qualities and attributes
I want to strengthen you know as a CEO
so that I sort of looked at it that way
as I created you know sort of this group
of folks who could sort of help and
guide were they people do that contact
with before or well no no they were all
people who had somehow been in my orbit
and then I thought well let's just try
to make this formal in some way and
let's just see if they would agree to do
this and they they all said yeah and
wanted to do that yes so long as you do
that to me in return which was a very
nice flattering thing I I'm sure it
doesn't work that way but that's been
very useful and and believe me I did end
up using that board when I went through
my seat the CEO search so 150 days ago
our founder who'd been running
Conservation International for 30 years
stepped down and you know and I became
the CEO and last year the board went
through a very challenging process of
trying to decide who the next CEO and
what the next leadership team would look
like and it's a very scary moment for an
organization because over half of the
CEOs who come in after founder fail and
actually if you want to get the job you
want to be the one in waiting like
seriously like that's what typically
happens new CEO comes in they fail and
either the old CEO comes back or the
person in Waiting kind of
the role and then runs it so it's
fraught with challenges and dangers all
over the place and I really didn't think
I would get it I thought there was a
chance I would get it but I was really
worried about it for lots of reasons
including my color to be absolutely
honest and this these groups of this
mentoring group honest to god coached me
them and a couple of other people really
helped coach me through this can you
share any of the advice you're wondering
a simple one so this is such an amazing
thing and I've applied for other jobs
before like kind of like the CEO or top
level person job and not got that three
times in the past I've been rejected for
that get very close and then somehow
they talked me out of it or I get
rejected here's what I was doing so they
would ask me so do you like to tell me
about this so why do you want the job
and I like well look I've got a good
career I don't really need this but you
know if it was the right thing you know
you kind of had this like kind of long
meandering story about saying you know
I'm not totally bested like yeah I could
do this but I could do lots of other
things and I actually feel that way in a
lot of ways right so in a lot of ways I
think I'm definitely I didn't start my
life thinking I want to be the CEO of
Conservation International there was
never a dream was never a goal never ago
the goal was much is goes to have impact
and really care how I had impact but
what these guys said to me was like one
guy actually said this to me said that
is not the right answer
I want you to repeat after me say I will
walk through a wall to get this job I
say it like really gets X I walked
through it says now when you go into
that interview they're gonna ask you
this question and I want you to repeat
this I will walk through so he did first
question why do you want this job
tell us what prepared you for this job I
said let me make one thing clear I will
walk through a wall together anyway
great because guess what most times when
you're hiring people and I do this all
the time I hire people all the time and
so amazed that I didn't listen to my own
role you want someone who gives you the
confidence that they will solve the
problems that you don't want to deal
with right you want someone who coming
in say you know what I got this you
don't want someone to come in and say I
don't know if I really want it convince
me and
and they start negotiating day one you
don't want to do that it's a very very
simple rule
so whatever job you go for start by
saying let me be clear I really want
this work job I will walk through a wall
to get this job now let me tell you what
makes me so great for this and then slay
it out you can negotiate later it's
really some point when you sent the
emails out to recruit this x-men team of
mentors to formal structure well a
couple of questions and this won't go on
for hours don't worry guys even though
it could and it might later with tequila
I don't know why I keep thinking of
tequila we could psychoanalyze that
later do you interact with these mentors
as a group or is it all one to
one-on-one although they know about
one-on-one because getting them together
as a group would be too impossible yeah
do you block out say a week every
quarter just to schedule them in batches
yeah yeah I did I schedule it around
travel that I have in the city so I do
this as much as I can in person unless I
have a crisis or an emergency I just
need to get on the phone and then
they're always willing like I literally
today I had a little manic crisis I
literally had a CEO of a company I
didn't want to name that enormous
enormous enormous company he would
turned my car today it's so far it's
like I'm so sorry took me so long to get
back to you and like you're kidding me
and he's like they you know once you get
that relationship with that few
individuals it does work if you can
really work very well did you make did
you say hey let's grab coffee and then
make the pitch in person or did you lay
it out I made it either no I did I don't
think I did by email I think I did all
by phone or when I met them in person
after back the first coffee so the
people I knew well I did by phone and
the people I'll tell you one thing
though I do take it sort of seriously so
when I go to see them they're two things
that I never make informal like two
things that I never make informal one is
when I talk to my board my organization
board or my group of mentors board which
means I put on a shirt I kind of you
know I put on a jacket if it's
appropriate I just what
away you want to do it and it's not
about dress code but whatever you wanted
to do it you want to make sure they
understand that you are using and taking
their hour really seriously
so just don't waste time with that the
other thing I do I always take seriously
when I ask people for money it's
something that I never do kind of on the
I never asked someone for a donation or
to fund conservation in tents or when
I'm having a drink with them or when I'm
like fly fishing with them while going
on a hike with them because people don't
wanna be hit up all the time the same I
mean if you want to just go do that and
like enjoy it and have fun and then you
want to say can I meet with you at 3
o'clock tomorrow afternoon ok I mean we
do at 8 a.m. tomorrow or today or
whatever it is you want to like just
clean up show up and be straight about
it ok it said last like two questions 20
questions ago but when you're preparing
for one of these meetings yeah what does
it look like I mean you're trying to
make give 60 minutes with such and such
super hot shot what's the format of the
hour it often depends at this point it
depends on what the major thing that I'm
dealing with has been and what's been
kind of bugging me on my mind that I
really could you give an example or is
it abuse you know I mean look look
there's no is not a big surprise anytime
a founder leaves an organization there
are is there so here's a really
legitimate answer so I was not the only
internal candidate going for this job
there were two other very very good
candidates for this job as well and they
both could do this job they both could
be CEOs and my number one task as soon
as I knew I was going to get this job
was to figure out a way to keep them it
almost never happens and they think what
you've just done you've now lost the
second best person to run your
organisation just walked out your door
it almost never happens so that was
something I prepared for I thought about
how I might try to approach it I went to
them and I said this is a problem it's a
big problem tell me what I need to do to
be able to do this and they gave me some
of not all of them I mean different
people and you got a pic and you know
you got a filter that advice but the two
individuals I went to Amy incredibly
good advice that I followed to
tea and it served me well because I
think it's every mile because both those
individuals are incredibly valuable and
and still part of constellation
attention well on that note I want to
thank you for so much good advice hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me and would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday in fact provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by 99designs
I've used 99designs for ages since even
before podcasting was the thing and I've
used them for all sorts of graphic
design needs they are fast and they are
convenient whether you need a logo a
website book cover or anything else I've
done competitions for instance for book
covers related to the 4-hour body
99designs makes great design accessible
to everyone and it makes the process so
much easier and I use them recently for
artwork and illustrations inside of my
cow of Seneca set of books so this is a
collection of stoic writing in modern
interviews and so on so for the Tao of
Seneca I decided to use there
one-two-one project service in this case
you invite a specific designer to
project agree on a price and then work
together until you're satisfied and the
artwork just blew my mind you have to
check it out I kid you not so you can
check out some of the artwork from top
Seneca as well as some artwork and logos
and so on that your fellow listeners
have had made at 99designs com forward
slash Tim that's 99designs comm forward
slash tip i really suggest you check it
out and right now you guys can receive a
free $99 upgrade on your first project
this gets you I think one hundred and
thirty percent more submissions so
people who want to work with you and
give you first drafts of what you're
looking for
to access your free design please visit
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
click the link on the landing page
that's 99designs comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
peloton and I'd heard about peloton over
and over again but I ended up getting a
peloton bike in the whole system after I
saw my buddy Kevin rose known forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic
you look great what the hell have you
been up to he's always doing a weird
diet or another but it only lasts like a
week or two so he always regresses to
the mean after like 75 beers and he said
I've been doing peloton 5 days a week
now that caught my attention because
Kevin does nothing five days a week and
you know I love you Kevin
but it really piqued my curiosity ended
up getting a system and it's become an
integral part of my week I love it and I
really didn't expect to love it at all
because I find cycling really boring
usually but peloton is an indoor cycling
bike that brings live studio classes
right into your home
you know if we're worried about fitting
classes in your schedule or making it to
a studio and sometimes we commute etc
new classes are added every day and this
includes options led by elite New York
City instructors in your own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
Wilbur's and design high intensity
training sessions that are shorter of 20
minutes and I think Kevin's favorite is
Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or in
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not and it fits
with no problems peloton is offering all
of you guys listeners of Tim Ferriss
show a special offer and it is actually
special visit one peloton that's o-n-e
PE l OT on1 peloton comm and enter the
code Tim all caps TI m at checkout to
receive $100 off accessories with your
peloton bike purchase now you might say
man accessories wait I don't need fancy
towels or whatever other supplemental
bits and pieces you know the shoes you
need you need the clip in shoes and
those are in the accessory categories so
this hundred dollars off is a very legit
hundred dollars off so if you want to
get in your workouts if you want a
convenient and really entertaining way
to do high-intensity interval training
or anything else or you just want to get
a fantastic gift for someone check out
pillow time one pallet on comm and enter
the code Tim again that's Oh n EP PL o t
om calm and enter the goat image check
out to receive $100 off any accessories
including the shoes that you will want
to get check it out one peloton comm
code Tim
[Applause]
you